Whoopi Goldberg and did you know she was
a card-carrying geek well let's check
some of that out here we go
I'm a woman of a certain age who's
always grown up with Superman and Batman
and Supergirl and all and all of the DC
and and Marvel Universe's and there's
nothing out there for us for women of a
certain age I want to see you know
somebody who saves the earth who looks a
little bit like me who was behind is a
little bit bigger whose chest is on the
floor but when it's a superpowers Roku
she could slap a whole nation of people
on a way to taking care of business
that's what I want and you don't find a
lot of humor you know I'm still trying
to think of a superhero with a big ass I
can't there isn't there's not there are
not everyone is still I'm talking about
natural and natural
fifty-year-old natural on the body of a
superhero yeah
because superheroes nope nothing says
superheroes have to be fit yeah of
course I tweeted this once and I said
how come no one's talking about this
Superman does not need muscles no if the
Superman okay with me oh here's the deal
what those superheroes are realistic it
was not Marvel but it did get put out
bill not the kungfu guy no way
oh wow